I have a saying that
your food is your flag.
Food can tell us where we
come from and who we are.
I'm a culinary historian,
historic interpreter,
and the James
Beard Award-winning
author of "The Cooking Gene."
The last thing
people will give up
as they make journeys and
migrations is their food
culture.
You have to look at
one particular dish,
and then you can trace it
back to its origin story;
and you ask the question, "why
did my family make that food?"
You begin to get a
picture of how you're
situated in a larger story.
This class is not a
full-on cooking school
of African-American
culinary technique.
It's about new ways to express
our relationship to food
through writing,
through storytelling,
through genealogy.
What you will learn, is how to
document your own food story
and have a greater context
for where we come from.
Go to the eldest people who are
able to tell you the stories
and answer your questions.
You're going to have a moment
where you close your eyes
and you open them,
and that entire table
will be surrounded
by the people that
populated that person's life.
You have to be willing to go
into the positive and negative
aspects of your family
history and journey
if you really want
to do this work.
We have to talk about
traumatic stuff--
history, the concept of
race, that potato famine,
that Holocaust,
that slave trade.
That's only part of the
puzzle, but in confronting
the issues that
come off of that,
we become better,
because we understand
what it took to get us here.
What I'm trying to offer you
is a little bit of insight
you can do your own
journeying through food
to find the ancestral
wisdom in the kitchen that's
right for you.
And if I can do it, I hope
that you will as well;
I hope that you will
have the strength
to say that your story
matters as much as mine does.
I'm Michael Twitty, and
this is MasterClass.